[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
encadrer les influenceurs sur les
réseaux sociaux
avec un nombre estimé de 150 000
influenceurs en France le secteur de
l'influence commerciale est en plein
développement tout en demeurant non
régulée au quotidien des millions de
Français sont confrontés aux dérives de
certains influenceurs avec la promotion
trompeuse voire dangereuse de certains
objets et services face à ce constat une
proposition de loi en tant cadrer
l'influence sur les réseaux sociaux le
statut des personnalités qu'il exerce et
des agences qui organisent le texte vise
ainsi à lutter contre la propagation de
pratiques commerciales trompeuses ou
frauduleuses sur internet pour que le
monde de l'influence ne soit plus une
zone de non-droit mais répondent à des
règles de protection des consommateurs
en commission puis en séance publique le
Sénat a rééquilibré le texte afin de
mieux encadrer l'influence commerciale
et de lutter de façon plus ciblée contre
les diverses dérives des influenceurs
tout d'abord les sénateurs ont clarifié
le cadre légal en rappelant que les
règles existantes en matière de
publicité et de promotion s'appliquent
déjà au marketing d'influence pour aller
plus loin ils ont incité à davantage de
sincérité en rendant obligatoire
l'affichage de la mention publicité dans
les publications
sur le plan sanitaire les sénateurs ont
étendu le champ de l'interdiction de la
promotion à l'abstention thérapeutique
au sachet de nicotine et au traitement
médicaux médicamenteux ou chirurgicaux
portant atteinte à la protection de la
santé en complément le Sénat a ciblé
d'autres dérives en interdisant aux
influenceurs d'interagir ou de se mettre
en scène sur les réseaux sociaux avec
des animaux non domestiques ou encore de
promouvoir des abonnements à des
conseils ou des pronostics sportifs
enfin le Sénat a voulu fixer des
sanctions réellement dissuasives pouvant
aller jusqu'à deux ans d'emprisonnement
et 300 000 euros d'amende si les
interdictions publicitaires ne sont pas
respectées ou si un influenceur
dissimule la véritable intention
commerciale de sa publication
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]